this is not going to be a normal video
we're sending garlic bread loads of
people have launched loads of objects on
balloons usually as publicity stunts but
despite a lot of breathless press
releases those objects haven't been
launched into space most standards
organizations agree that space
officially starts at the completely
arbitrary common line 100 kilometres up
and balloons like that one I only get
about a third of the way there and we're
definitely not sending anything into
orbit orbit requires tens of thousands
of miles an hour of speed that's what
all the Rockets are for we're using a
weather balloon it's a large one
actually today we're going as high as we
can with this payload it's very cold on
the way up it gets warmer as you
approached that sort of altitude so it's
coldest just above the jet stream and
then getting slightly warmer again it
gets back down to about zero about where
the balloon will pop the idea that all
those publicity stunts actually made it
to space is helped by the fact that the
fisheye lens on some of the cameras that
they use means that the curve of the
earth looks a lot more dramatic than it
really is at that height now we're using
cameras that correct for that so what
you'll see on screen is more or less
what you'd see up there so we're not
saying space we're saying the edge of
space which is basically just a
marketing term but the atmosphere is so
thin up there about 1% of the pressure
at ground level that it's close enough
why garlic bread because it's delicious
and because someone already sent Pizza
up in a balloon a few years ago this
garlic bread is delicious it's homemade
well apart from the baguette oh there's
some homemade garlic butter on there
with some real nice parmesan on there I
although I did make it 5 o'clock this
morning so it's gonna be a near vacuum
isn't gonna be possibly frozen I mean
we're gonna send half up in the sky with
the balloon and leaving half on earth
for comparison taste test as it goes up
the atmosphere is getting thinner and
thinner and there's less unless they're
pushing in the balloon itself get bigger
and bigger
so eventually the balloon will pop and
the equipment will parachute down to the
ground and we'll go and recovery
[Music]
we normally predict the landing spots
are within about five miles when we
launch the balloon we're tracking the
balloon using some radio trackers they
send a signal with the GPS position to
the ground and that's put on a map and
we chase the balloons predicted landing
spot I've done lots of high-altitude
ballooning I've been doing it now for
about ten years
never lost one set one to its doom a
couple of times all sorts of food items
have been launched into the stratosphere
the BBC sent wedding cake up as part of
a children's show but a punchline at the
end was that no one actually ate it I
have yet to find any balloon launched
food that was actually eaten after
landing and the main reason for that is
you have no idea where it's going to
land what it's going to land in or what
animals will have got to it first the
Box I've design has a GPS and a servo
and a piece of string and some Springs
as it comes down it closes the server a
thousand meters above the ground so now
we have to get in our cars and go
chasing the payload
it's just coming to land somewhere about
a half mile ahead
so dari keep your eyes on the sky I'll
keep my eyes on the road let's go it's
just on the end of that let's do it yeah
yeah really good not bad right spice
bread is it cold it's not that much
whole no that tore completely
differently so that that one ripped that
has been frozen so I see the color of
the middle of the room why - isn't it
this way - the stratosphere and I'm
heating it thank you very much - Steve
Randall from random aerospace and -
Barry Lewis from my virgin kitchen I
don't actually know what I did on this
I'm basically DJ Khaled's at this point
yeah DJ
[Laughter]